So time for another reflection. For this reflection, I want you to go out. And
find an example, where you got stuck
crossing either the gulf of execution, or the
gulf of evaluation. And you can share
your example, via whatever format you'd like. So
photos, video, text. As long as your example
clearly communicates, where you got stuck and why.
>> So, here's a tip while you're going
out in the world, and looking for difficult situations.
Look for a place where somebody has applied, maybe a
hand-made label. That gives additional instructions on how to do
something. This is often a, users call for help. This
wasn't designed right. I need extra help. So maybe there's
a Post-it note on something, that gives some additional explanation.
It might also be an official sign. So here's a
few examples. One, well this door is an emergency exit.
But it actually isn't clear that it's an emergency exit.
So somebody had to hand make a sign, that said don't
go out this door. Or the alarm will sound. Well, then
people might actually be confused. because if there was an emergency,
they wouldn't know whether they can go out that door or
not. And look at this coffee maker. Well for some reason,
and maybe it's a cultural constraint here. Is that red means
on. No sorry, I got that wrong. Red actually means off.
Boy, that's confusing. So they added a handmade label here, that said.
The red light when it's on, means the coffee machine is off.